protests have continued across the
country since George Floyd died now over
three weeks ago protesters have been
calling for change and President Trump
is now taking a big step toward police
reform
Skylar Henry is in Washington with
details President Trump declared he's
the law and order president even as he
signed an executive order encouraging
new standards for police reform if we
must improve accountability increase
transparency and invest more resources
in police training recruiting and
community engagement the order
encourages police departments to collect
and track excessive force complaints it
has incentives for police to update
their training certifications and it
employs mental health professionals to
work with police to respond to some
incidents as part of this new
credentialing process Cho calls will be
banned except if an officer's life is at
risk the president also met privately
with african-american families impacted
by police brutality or racially
motivated civilian violence including
the family of Ahmad R burry who was
gunned down while jogging in Georgia
President Trump says he will work with
Congress on additional reform
legislation being worked on on Capitol
Hill
the house is expected to vote on its
legislation next week but the Senate is
not expected to vote on its bill until
next month
the popular anger over long simmering
issues of police brutality and racial
justice has reached the tipping point
there is no reason to wait there is no
reason to delay senator Tim Scott who
will unveil the Senate GOP plan tomorrow
says it's a mistake to wait until after
the fourth of July to vote on the
legislation
Skyler Henry CBS News the White House